بعد دفن الجثمان
[موسيقى]
يقال يعني حسب ما نقل اليه تم نقله الى
مكان اخر لانه
احد المواسير اللي تنقل الماء
يعني انفتحت على القبر
واضطروا ان ينقلوا الى مكان اخر بطريقه
سلسه وبطريقه امنه يعني المعلومات او يعني
ما بدنا نسميها معلومات ولكن ما سمعناه عن
انه تم التنكيل بالجثه وسحبها من القبر
غير صحيحه
يمكن ان تنفي ذلك طبعا
يحرس الجثمان من قبل الاقرباءه فما كان
يسمحوا لاي واحد يطوله
[موسيقى]
الخروج خارج العراق
والمعلومات التي سمعناها عن ان رؤساء
اجانب ومنهم الرئيس الاسبق في امريكا جورج
بوش الابن كان يريدوا ان يرى مقيد عند
اعتقاله اقصد هذه صحيحه نعم لكن اعترضوا
عليها كانت تعيدها
واعترض عليها انه راح يولد نغمه اذا طلع
بالطريق اللي كان يهدف الى بوش راح يولد
نغمه ويولد يعني صخب وسخط لدى الشعب
العراقي
ويكبل القوات الامريكيه المقاومه راح تشتد
وتخسر القوات الامريكيه كيف تؤكد مثل هذه
المعلومه يعني من
يعني هذه معلومه قد تكون حتى على الجانب
الامريكي السريه
ما يعني احنا معلوماتنا مثلا على المحاكمه
عن
يوم الاعدام من داخل المعتقل يعني من يعني
هسه شلون هسه الموجودين بالحكم بده واحد
يطلع اسرار الاخر نعم يعني
معلومات
ونتوثق من مصداقيتها هل تعتقد ان القوات
الامريكيه هي التي كانت تريد ان تقوم
باعدام صدام حسين ام انها كانت يعني كان
بامكانها او تريد ان تطلق سراحه ولكن
اسراع السياسيين العراقيين الجدد بتنفيذ
هذه العمليه هو الذي حال دون اتمام مخططات
اخرى القوات الامريكيه كان ما يعنيها
موضوع دامه اكملت المهمه اللي اجت من
اجلها ازاحه الرئيس بمفهومهم لكن بوش
الرئيس الامريكي كان عنده حقد شخصي على
الرئيس صدام
اللي اسرع بعدامه الموجودين الان يعني
المنظومه الحكم اللي اتوا بها الجامعه
الامريكي يعني اللي كانوا
هم اللي اسرعوه ولحوا
بالتنفيذ الاعدام